JANET CONRAD: So I really
love teaching Junior Lab.
And I really like it
the way that it is.
I like its structure
and so forth.
But you cannot sit in that lab
and not come up with new ideas
for experiments.
And I have one that I
would really love to do.
I am on a neutrino experiment.
I was the head of the neutrino
experiment for a while, which
was called MiniBooNE.
MiniBooNE stands for
Booster Neutrino Experiment.
So MiniBooNE was a small
And in neutrino physics,
small is 800 tons.
It's [CHUCKLES] 40 feet high.
It's a big detector.
And inside of it, it had all
of these photo detectors that
lined the inside and when a
neutrino interaction occurred,
you got a little
bit of light that
came out from the
charged particle
that the neutrino produced.
It turns out that charged
particle was traveling faster
than the speed of
light in a medium,
in the oil that was
in the detector.
Nothing goes faster than the
speed of light in a vacuum,
but things can go faster than
the speed of light in material.
When that happens,
you get the equivalent
of a sonic boom, a
kind of photonic boom.
Bam, out come a whole
bunch of photons.
And people love this idea
that things can go faster
than the speed of light.
And it's really so
neat to see that light.
It's called shrink of light.
And so, what I
would like to do, is
I would like to build a small
version of my experiment
MiniBooNE, which we
would call TinyBooNE.
[CHUCKLES] And TinyBooNE would
be about one meter across.
And it would have photo
detectors, tiny little photo
detectors.
They're called silicon
photo-multipliers.
All along one side.
And we would put a beta
source in the middle of it.
And out would come in electron.
That electron, if you choose
the right beta source,
is actually high enough
energy that it will actually
produce a little bit
of Cherenkov light.
And you can actually
see the Cherenkov light.
And so as with any of the
Junior Lab experiments,
we have to have two
things you can measure.
All the Junior Lab
experiments are
designed so there's two
things you can measure.
One which one partner
focuses on and one which
the other partner focuses on.
And so the things that you
would measure in TinyBooNE,
one of them would be how
the Cherenkov light turns on
with energy, given the source,
which would be a strontium
to yttrium source.
And then the other would
be to use that beta decay
spectrum to set a mass limit.
Not a very good mass
limit, but a mass
limit on the mass
of the neutrino.
And I think it
would be really fun.
I would just love to build this.
It's just not possible
to sit in there
and not dream up what
experiment you would like to do.